- How you doing?
Do we have any golfers?
Anybody who plays golf, likes golf?
Good, I have a good golf story.
Now, this goes back to 1958
in Fort Worth, Texas.
There was a...
The championship for the
Blind Golfers Association
had their award ceremony
for the best blind golfer.
And there was a guy, his
name was Charley Boswell.
He was the national champion blind golfer.
And because of that,
he got the opportunity
to play a round of golf with Ben Hogan.
Ben Hogan was the premier
golfer of that era.
Like Arnold Palmer, Jack Nicklaus,
Tiger Woods, that kind of level.
So, Charley was very thrilled to meet them
'cause this was his idol.
But Charley lost his
sight during World War II.
He was a really good athlete,
played football, played baseball.
And then during World War II,
he tried to save one of his comrades
in a tank that was burning.
And a shell blew up and he lost his sight,
so he didn't know what to do.
He came back, he took up
golf, never done it before.
So, he gets to meet the
best golfer of that era
and gets to play with him.
And Ben Hogan was in awe of
him 'cause he could play blind.
So, he said...
Charley said, "Hey, how
about if we play for money?"
And Ben, you know, go like,
"Wait, I'm like the best
golfer in the world.
I can't play for money for you.
It's unfair, you're blind."
And Charley is undeterred, he says,
"$1,000 a hole."
And Ben's like, "I can't play golf.
No, that would be unfair."
So, Charley says, "Are you chicken?"
Now, Ben is very competitive.
He says, "No, I'm not chicken.
Okay, you want me to play, I'll play.
No, I'm not gonna hold
back, I'm gonna play hard."
He goes, "I would expect that from you."
So,
Charley says...
Or Ben says to Charley, "Okay.
What time?"
Goes, "Tonight at 10."
So, this is an example of how
the playing field can be evened out.
Now, if you're...
Let's switch to another sport, football.
So, football, who has the advantage?
The offense or the defense, right?
The offense obviously
has advantage, right?
The quarterback gets to
play, calls it in the huddle,
comes in line, he sees
what the defense is set,
he figures out, what am I gonna do?
You know, the defense has to guess.
It's first down, maybe they're gonna run.
It's third down, maybe they're gonna pass,
but maybe they're gonna fake 'em out.
Are they gonna pass?
They gonna hand off,
they gonna fake the handoff pass,
run around, you know,
there's so many things that could be done.
So, we wanna say, how can
we even out the field?
How can we get into the
minds of the attackers
and make that playing field level,
just like Charley was able to level it out
with the world's greatest golfer?
So, I'm gonna pass it over to Memo here,
and he's gonna talk about
what our new deception technology does.
- Thank you, Rick.
(Rick laughs)
Well, now let's focus our
attention to the attackers, okay?
Just like Rick was mentioning.
When we are defending our systems,
sometimes we focus
and have our attention into the
designing defensive strategies, right?
And we focus on the attacks,
but not on the attackers.
And by doing this,
we can overlook something super important.
The humans...
Sorry, the attackers are just humans
like everyone in this room, right?
Humans with a brain that
works in the same way than us.
This is very important.
Understanding this is key to
implement defensive strategies
much more efficient, right?
We want to influence the
decision making of the attackers
to protect our systems.
Sorry.
But how can we influence the
decision making processes
of our attackers?
To answer this, let me
introduce these two concepts
of behavioral science, nudge and sludge.
Both are ways of describing
how to influence the
decision making, okay?
But in opposite ways.
On this side, we have nudge,
which is influencing in
a positive way, okay?
Let's say make it easier,
make it more simple.
Like here, we have a
password strength meter
to help the user create a strong password.
This is a very simple example.
Or on the bottom part, we have
a reminder of a application
to just do your daily exercise.
This is a example of nudge.
And on the other hand, we have sludge.
We have sludge,
which is to make the
process more complicated.
To add steps, add
complexity, add friction.
This is an example of sludge.
And here on the center we have a CAPTCHA.
A CAPTCHA has good intentions, right?
Is to block the bad actors.
But sometimes, the CAPTCHAs
add friction, complexity.
The legitimate users,
sometimes they see this
as additional steps
and end up just giving
up and going elsewhere.
This is an example of sludge.
And we can think of many examples.
Like, I'm sure here,
everyone has experienced
the subscription services on the internet.
It's always super easy to subscribe.
It's just one click away.
But what happens when you want to cancel?
There are several steps.
Sometimes you get an offer.
One free month, don't cancel.
Just extend three months more.
This is a very common
example of sludge and nudge.
And in the case of the attackers,
we want to use sludge for good.
We want to add friction, right?
We want to...
We can impose friction to
our attackers in our benefit
to create better defensive strategies.
We can influence their behavior
and decision making with sludge.
And what is the cost to the
attackers if we add friction?
There are different costs.
We have quantitative costs
and qualitative costs.
First, we have the obvious.
If we add friction into the process,
if we make the process more
difficult to the attackers,
we have everything that
costs money and effort,
we have this quantitative cost,
all the foregone opportunities.
But there's also the qualitative costs.
And we have reputational.
If we make them fail, the attackers,
they will lose credibility,
it will be harder to recruit,
it will be more difficult
to get new clients.
And also we have informational cost,
which refers to the
effort that the attackers
put to get more information
about the next targets.
If we add invaluable information,
we create more cost to them.
And finally,
and this is the reason of the
title of this presentation,
is the psychological cost.
If we add frustration, shame,
and confusion to the attackers
by making the process more
difficult, by adding friction,
we add this cost.
Now, let's see how at Fastly
we are using sludge for good.
And this is with deception.
Deception has been used
over the course of history
in many contexts, especially in warfare.
That's why we have here the Trojan Horse,
which the Greeks used against
the Trojans to win the war.
In cybersecurity,
we all know about the concept of honeypot,
which is a way to deceive the attackers
to get more information
about their tactics, okay?
In the nature, we also have many examples,
like animals changing their
appearance to hunt their preys
or protect against the predators.
Deception is not playing dirty.
Deception is about leveraging what we know
about our enemy tactics
in our benefit, okay?
This is deception.
And now Rick is going to explain to you
how Fastly is introducing deception
into our cybersecurity products.
- Okay, so this is kind of the
brainchild of our product VP
who has a deep security background
and a background in behavioral economics.
So, we wanna try and get
into the head of these guys.
We wanna,
like you said, make them
frustrated so they'll go away
or they won't bother this
particular site anymore.
So, this is just the
start of what we're doing.
And right now, the way we're gonna do it
is we're looking at account takeovers.
So, this is our WAF product,
Next-Gen WAF from Fastly,
where you can set the parameters
on when you want to trigger
the deception to happen.
So, basically, what it's gonna do,
once it's hit that deception trigger,
either by a signal that
says this is a bad bot,
or suspected bad bot,
or it's a certain path,
certain IP, certain country,
all that is open and configurable,
so you can decide the trigger point
when you want it to start deceiving.
But once it starts, gets
that deception going,
it's gonna take...
That guy's gonna go iterate through
his username and password
to try and find one that works
'cause he paid money for it.
So, we're gonna make all of them bad,
so if he has a good username and password,
we're going to scramble it,
send it back to the origin
and it'll say, you know,
that's bad, it's a...
Wrong username and password you'll see.
So, everyone will start seeing like that
and he won't get any feedback
on why, what's wrong?
See, if we just blocked it,
"Ah, he blocked me.
Maybe he rate limited me.
Okay, I logged in more
than 10 times a minute."
And they'll go down to nine.
"Oh, I tried this path,
maybe I'll try another path."
Something like that.
In this case, he doesn't
know what's going on,
so we're effectively blocking
him and frustrating him.
So, what makes this more important is,
as I just mentioned,
when he's under attack
and he gets the signal, he can retool.
He sees, "Okay, that's the offense
or that's the defense you have in place.
I know how to get around that.
I could go this way or that way."
But here, he doesn't know.
He thinks he has a bad list.
He doesn't know what they're doing.
Now, again, as Memo mentioned,
honeypots have been around for a while.
The problem is they're typically
a separate infrastructure.
So, you have your production,
then you have your honeypot,
you gotta keep 'em in sync,
you gotta keep 'em exact,
you gotta run two instances.
You know, it'd be costly.
A lot of engineering work.
You know, it could be worth
it, but it's a lot of effort.
In this case, the genius here
is we put it right in line.
It's right in line with
your normal WAF workflow.
And we could take those triggers,
and again, instead of blocking,
we're just scrambling
the password and username
and sending back, "Hey,
that was a bad one."
But we're not blocking them.
So, it's easy to put it
in and out and tune it
without having to create all
this other infrastructure,
which is costly and difficult to maintain.
So, to mention, this is a start.
We're doing it with account takeover
and we plan on expanding it,
putting it into other areas,
API and other types of attack vectors that
we're going to make it look
deceptive in different ways.
And the beauty here is
it allows security people
to easily use this
without having to go deep into the code
and build things that might be
more difficult and costly to maintain,
'cause it's a GUI-driven interface,
very easy to enable it and log it,
or even try it and see
what it would've deceived
before you're ready to
really put it in production.
And this is all part
of a defense in depth.
So, we see there's a whole myriad of tools
that you need to have in place
to protect those attackers.
And this is something that
Fastly provides as well.
The deception's just one part of our WAF.
We can also do rate limiting.
We have DDoS on the front end,
which can detect DDoS
attacks and block them.
And then we're secured down by design.
Deep inside our CDN and our WAF,
we make sure all the code,
everything there is secure.
And you have this whole defensive depth,
it's all logged, it's all API-driven,
it all is driven by Terraform.
It's very easy to roll
it forward, roll it back,
and manage it and iterate on it.
So, again, we want to
even the playing field,
like I mentioned with
Charley and the golf,
and try and
fool those attackers before
they can do their damage.
Thank you.